alright good morning everybody thank you
so much for coming to secrets to apps
and game success on Google Play my name
is andreas poya this is brian quimby we
both work on google play in business
development and help game and app
developers to be successful on the
platform
so i guess i use this
strong start guys here we go and you
already know that there we go so
previously do Google bleh I worked on a
team that helped game and app developers
to get additional users and so many app
developers told me Andreas I have a
problem conversion tracking is difficult
and really getting a good understanding
of where my users come from was a big
deal and a big challenge actually form
any app and game developers so that
could be any of the traffic sources
could be YouTube it could be surge it
could be AdMob any of the organic
traffic sources and it was really a
challenge so to overcome this challenge
we announced at i/o a new tool a new
report that helps you getting a better
understanding about your user
acquisition channels and so this is
actually the report that you can see
here so you can follow now your users
from the stop play store listing to the
install and tulip purchase and this
report is really beautiful to get the
full understanding of your funnel the
great thing is you can even follow you
can even follow your users to the next
stage which is actually the repeat
purchases but that's not everything
beyond the beyond the funnel you can
actually also see the traffic sources
the traffic sources can be organic on
Google Play but it can be also beyond
that any third party traffic source that
you have
and so you can drill down on the traffic
sources that can be Google search
keywords that can be UTM tag traffic or
any third party traffic source that you
have and so now with this full
understanding of your your traffic
funnel so from the user who comes to the
Play Store listing to the Installer the
purchaser to the repeat purchaser you
have a full understanding of that funnel
but on top of that you also know where
the users come from this allows you to
take action and you can optimize your
store listing so I want to take into
this a little more how to optimize your
store listing when you get started
initially it's very important to really
think about your icon you're a bike on
your game icon this is this helps every
user to find your app your game not only
the Play Store but also on the phone and
so you can do a couple of things one
recommendation that we have is keep your
icon fresh you can even seasonally
adjusted for holidays the second very
important piece is your title think
about it keep it short keep it unique
you can see here actually a word play
and really keep it unique and special at
the same time be thoughtful about your
brand you may actually have a version
two you may have a second appt at a
later stage make sure that you are
thoughtful about your brand and then
thirdly it's really important also think
about your description there are a
couple of things to keep in mind keep it
short keep it simple but also have
bullet points there and there is one
important thing whenever you write your
apt description also make sure to check
it out on your phone to see the apt
description if everything is above the
fold that you really want to communicate
and so that brings me to store listing
experiments store listing experiments is
a product that we launched to really
help you getting a better understanding
of the performance of your store listing
so that allows you to understand how
many conversions do you actually get
from the users
visit your store listing and so you can
test for various different parts of the
store listing that can be the title that
can be description that can be all the
graphic assets that you have on your
store listing and how does that work so
we recommend that you start with the
icon our tests show showed that you
actually will see the most impact on the
icon so test early and make the first
thing that you really really want to
test out and so I have a so there are a
couple of other best practices here that
we really want to share with you start
with an idea in mind some hypotheses
that you want to test for only test one
thing at one time to make sure that you
can trust your results and you know what
drove the Chitwood drove the impact then
also iterate and learn from that and
then also make sure that the test that
you run is actually statistically
significant whenever you do so the
results are actually a banner with in
the developer console that shows you as
soon as the test is significant and you
can move on and be sure that you can
trust the results and then the great
thing about this whole feature on this
whole product is that this is all free
there is not even code needed for it we
have a couple of examples here the first
I want to show you is congregate the saw
and ninety-one percent increase in
installs just for testing the icon
that's pretty amazing ninety-one percent
from the first control to the last that
you can see here the server and see a
ninety-one percent increase in installs
here is another example rovio tested
three rounds so they started the first
part and then they figure out oh this is
actually a good result they continue the
second round a third round and then they
really understood which icon is actually
the best for their game here we have
another example that's one of our
partners that will work with closely
they tested a very small thing that's
really just the screenshot on a store
listing of the game the one thing they
modified is
actually showing now gameplay within
that screenshot instead of just showing
the screenshot and that little tweak
actually increase the conversion rate by
six percent I will now hand over to
Brian who will talk to you about alpha
beta testing too bad I will not have a
clicker but alas thanks a lot Andre us
how cool is that right store listing
experiments free user testing put some
different icons put some different
descriptions figure out what's convert
and best for your users so now that you
have that solid Play Store listing I
kind of want to back up a little and
talk about you know some of the best
practices related to actually releasing
your app so what Google developer
console provides is an easy way for you
to prototype iterate test and then
eventually launch your app with alpha
beta testing and staged rollouts so this
is one of the top reasons that
developers tell us play is such a
fantastic platform to develop it for
this is a unique tool it's going to let
you get high quality results and really
take control of your app rollouts and we
see most of our successful developers
using these features so you're going to
start with an alpha test upload that APK
set it to the channel move on to beta
testing and then once you're convinced
that that package that new release that
you have is good we can do staged
rollouts releasing that APK to only a
percentage of your developers before
moving on to your full rollout we got
that stat up there right eighty percent
of the most successful apps of play are
using these staged rollouts and alpha
and beta testing so beta testing very
awesome feature in google play you can
distribute your app to only a subset of
users and get their feedback rather than
releasing it to everyone at once and
then you know crossing your fingers and
hoping you're not crashing on some
random device so beta testing users are
going to opt-in to be testing they can't
leave reviews and then they're not going
to be able to leaked confidential
features or something but I
posting something on your page you're
going to be able to have two different
versions that you can beta test with and
you know if you haven't ever launched on
play yet we definitely recommend that
you're starting out with using beta
testing so you can get the app out there
make sure that things are working out
right again before you move on to that
full rollout and then if your apps
already live you can test new features
in the beta Channel but then you put the
new apk up there upload it release it
out to a subset of those users good to
go this is what the beta testing tab
looks like within the developer console
you see you got the production one on
the left beta testing in the alpha
testing and just upload something to
that alpha testing or beta testing
channel you just going to click on that
upload new apk button right there so two
ways that we can go about testing our
new build open or closed closed alpha or
beta testing is invite only and managed
through google groups no more of the G+
communities if that was something that
was working you so this means all you
have to do is add an email address to
the group and then send your users that
link they can download the alpha and
beta builds now the other way you can do
it is actually have an open alpha or
open beta test this is going to give you
a custom URL that you can then send out
to as many users as you want if you want
to tweet it to some people if you want
to send it out maybe an email list that
you have for your power users or
subscribers so you know a number of top
developers have seen a lot of great
success starting with maybe the close
testing moving over to the open testing
none throwing up an example quick case
study for you guys help convince you
that this is an awesome way to go this
is the Guardian great newspaper out of
the UK over the past there's like a six
month period and they trialed every one
of their new features first in the beta
channel they uploaded the new nightly
builds to the alpha channel then
eventually pushed out to the public
beyond and so beyond you know just be
I'm getting the feedback it's a safe
place for them to test innovate an
experiment without any danger to the
brand no one who's seeing the live
version is not expecting any no that's
crashing there's too many bugs
everything is only in that beta Channel
and again everything's opt-in as well so
these users are seeing the link they're
clicking become a tester and that's how
they're getting access to the
new builds for the Guardian it used to
take about a month or so to launch new
features you know now let's get down to
just even even a week or two and they're
able to push some of these things out so
now that you have a beta build that
you're confident with maybe you started
with alpha you move to the beta channel
tried some in the open beta testing
maybe had to close beta testing at first
to work out any new bugs or kinks now
it's actually time to push to production
even the even then though we can still
only distribute that to a subset of
users to keep on testing keep on
iterating and make sure that everything
is going to be good to go this is staged
rollouts you can roll out that new apk
to a controlled percentage of users
these users are selected randomly they
won't know what build they're getting
when they go to the Play Store but
you're gonna have access to detailed
logs crash reports analytics you're
going to be able to see which is
happening depending on which version of
the APK that people got all you got to
do click upload new apk to production
then you're going to see that staged
rollout screen with these percentages
right five percent ten percent twenty
percent and then up to a hundred percent
for full rollout after you upload it you
look at the crash report you're looking
at bugs features user feedback you're
going to be able to iterate even then if
you want to take a new apk bump that up
and then publish that out to other
people you're going to be have the
ability to do that too and then
eventually once you're confident in that
build you've gone through the testing
process you've done a staged rollout you
can hit a hundred percent and fully push
that build out to production for
everyone to get so cool come on alpha
beta testing yeah there we go wake it up
in here I know I barely got to finish my
coffee this morning to it's all right so
we got a great build live but now I want
to talk real quick about some of the
intricacies of developing for those
users in international markets
localization of your apk and also your
Play Store listing is going to be really
key to you guys to make sure your app
successful no matter where your users
are located google play as you know
massive reach truly a global platform
you're going to be getting users from
all over and once you have a good
is that your app is working your app is
seeing downloads you want to make sure
that we can achieve your goals by really
reaching users in all these different
countries so the first thing to think
about once you want to go international
is making sure that your people can
actually understand your app understand
your listing and so we want to talk
about localization right you can
localize the strings within your apk you
can localize your screenshots your play
store listings as a quick incentive
quick plug if you come to the Google
Play office hours later and you are
interested in localization I have some
coupons that i can give you and i'll
walk through how you can actually use
the localization services provided
within the Play Developer console as
well localization making sure that your
app is translated to pricing for local
markets cool thing that we just throw
that with Google Play sub dollar pricing
so this is going to let you have very
very low prices depending on what
currency you want depending on what
region you want to have your app
published in and then three right at
performance if your app is being
launched in different markets we might
have to optimize for smaller download
sizes your ability to work on data
connections that aren't a strong low
memory use right the devices that people
have access to in some of these
different areas you want to make sure
that we're really thinking about these
things as we're developing our app I
just told you some some high-level
general tips how can you guys find
specific tips out though for your apps
good news within the optimization tips
section of the developer console you'll
see we now have a lot of awesome
localization tips so here's an example
on my to-do list right translate my
product descriptions add localized
graphics translate strings of my APK
you're going to find all of these tips
right within your developer console now
so you can take action on them and make
sure that your apk and your app is good
to go regardless of where the users are
who are downloading it what I just
talked about that first option
translating new Play Store listing
translating your apk super easy from
within the developer console now after
you just hit that store listing manage
translations you can add your own
translation text or you can purchase
translations for your Google Play Store
listing if you don't provide translation
text google play is going to either show
an automated translation or the default
language for your application if you
think about that neither are really
ideal if you have a user who speaks
another language who's visiting your app
visiting your Play Store listing and
wants to download your app so highly
recommend either adding your own
translation text for your Play Store
listing or you can purchase that
directly from the developer console in
addition to your store listing as I said
want to make sure that your apk itself
the strings within it are good to go as
well regardless of where your users are
Google makes this super easy using the
apk translation service you can either
purchase those strings again and
purchase those translations from the
developer console or you can add those
yourself so to get there with the dev
console right at the bottom you're going
to start or check progress under the apk
translation service upload your XML
files select your target language and
i'll go into real quick what that next
screen looks like in terms of actually
purchasing translated text & translation
options if you want to do that so you're
going to be presented with a list of
third-party vendors who are
pre-qualified by Google to offer
high-quality translations at competitive
prices you can upload the strings that
you want select the language to
translate into and then choose your
translation vendor based on price and
time once you purchase translations you
get an email from that vendor and then
the lawyers make me say the translations
are an independent business agreement
between you and your vendor you'll need
to work with your vendor directly to
manage any translation process and
deliverables thanks guys however all
built right within the developer console
you're going to be able to see the
progress pros / call back but it's going
to be it's great really good feature
come on slow it's awesome so last thing
I wanted to go over today something
called developer pages this is a new
relatively new feature that we just
launched this is going to let you have a
branded presence on the google play
store if you think about it when you
actually click on the developer name or
the title of an app you're going to see
that page that just has a bunch of apps
that that developer makes this is going
to let you transform that sort of
generic page and is something that's
awesome and is really representative of
your brand developer pages lets you
upload a graphic explain what your
company is all about and even pick a
special
up to feature at the top the developer
page is going to give you a single
destination to promote all of your apps
on Google Play and many of our top
partners one in four in fact have
already created their page you can check
out any do right here so they have that
nice banner at the top with some
promotional text graphics on top of that
you can see an icon for the developer
explanation and they had that featured
app easy to show off your brand and
cross promote your apps with Google Play
Developer pages that was it on mobile
and I know you guys mobile first tablet
first but developer pages also look
great on desktop browsers so this is you
do really cool app if you're a cord
cutter and want to see the where the
different shows are on right now this is
what the developer page looks like on
desktop again featured app they're
awesome graphic banner at the top some
descriptions and things like that so
super tactfully how do we actually build
a developer page and if we want to get
interactive I see a lot of you with your
laptops out feel free to fire up your
developer councils right now so
literally take five minutes we can walk
through it together on the left side
click settings developer page add your
information the top right so we'll start
out in English but your promotional text
on there it can be up to 140 characters
nothing else is 140 characters that I'm
thinking about so this is this is
perfect right up here you can add a
translation if you want and then again
stick your company website up there too
you'll need a developer icon and a large
header image at the top and then again
as an optional feature you can also add
a featured app so if someone's visiting
your developer page they're going to see
that app there at the top you can also
have your other apps list at the bottom
you have a promotion or seasonal special
you can rotate that featured app at the
top of your screen out I see everyone
really clicking and intensely typing so
I'm going to assume you're all building
developer pages with me right now it's
good
so that's actually all i had to go over
a couple things little housekeeping
items so first off as Andreas and I
mentioned we work on the business
development team of play if you guys are
interested in working with us to links
up there at the top jiko play apps if
you're an app developer gioco / play
games BD if your games developer that
will take you to a form you can fill
that out let us know your thoughts let
us know your priorities tell us about
your appt a bit and you can get back to
us give us feedback if you liked hearing
me up here ramble on about some things
if you didn't like it if you thought I'd
Reyes is way better than me I tend to
give us feedback that some forms link
right there and then as I mentioned
before we're going to be having office
hours so if you have questions about
play if you have questions about the
developer console feel free to stop by
as I mentioned will have coupons for
translation services you can use some of
those cool tools we're talking about and
google also just released a new secrets
to app success book so if you want to
swing by our office hours well hopefully
hook you up with one of these lots of
great content and each of the topics
that we covered today is also in this
book and a lot more detail so with that
I'm going to wrap up I think we'd
probably have maybe 15 minutes or so for
some questions or we can walk around and
talk to you guys too
so I have a few questions so you said
icon of the app is the most significant
impact you can do quite quickly and no
according to the bulbs I'm assuming you
don't change the appt you don't change
the icon in the app itself only on the
store is that something you've got to do
or so you would modify the D up I can
obviously that makes the most sense if
you test it actually at a very early
stage of development and so that's when
you actually want to test for the icon
and so you test it both on the store but
also for the app itself I guess what I'm
getting at if I have a different icon in
my app right I want I don't want to redo
boiler app just to change the icon so I
would change it on the Play Store but
then the app itself has a different icon
is that something that's okay you think
we're um I believe it's better if you
keep it consistent because it's kind of
like your brand also but it's it's it's
also where any user would find your app
begin either on the phone but also on
the Play Store so you want to make sure
that it's kind of consistent but clearly
when it's actually at an early stage you
can easily test for it and then you can
actually test various different
iterations without having to update the
app so if that is at an early stage I
think that's totally fine but generally
make sure to keep it consistent as well
okay that means if i want to change back
into the holidays i would need to deploy
a new APK just to change the icons in
heaven so within the developer console
you don't have to actually modify or
adjust the APK so that's just a change
with and developer console okay so there
may be a couple more questions do you
expand the number of one gauges nucleic
translation services because i used to
have to use them and then we will decide
to support some Nordic languages by
Norwegian Swedish Finnish so on and they
were not available so i had to switch to
different service hmm so is that
something that you guys keep changing I
haven't checked for a few months but
it's something that you expanding
constantly or like yeah I would check
again i'm pretty sure that there are a
lot of languages that are covered right
now off the top of my head i don't know
the specific ones but again because at
least if you're purchasing the
translations through google it's those
third-party vendors you should
be able to find someone out there who's
been vetted by Google who's going to be
able to translate into that language
that you want okay also you mentioned
that if you don't translate the store
description is shown either in default
language or other translated do we have
any control or that or it's like
automatic user setting yeah i'm not sure
if there's any specific control that you
have over saying which it is you know
the user will have their default
language and then i mean if you go on
the Play Store on desktop right there's
that little thing that pops is you want
Google to translate this and then they
can click it so I mean I guess there's
sort of some control the user clicks
that or not but I mean I'd say you know
best practice is probably just to have a
translation and therefore whatever
language the users are okay and the last
question is developer page do you have
any data on the impact that it makes is
it the worthy investment so I actually
just go do it right now you have any
weight anything yep so nothing specific
that we were going to share yet but you
know right now it's just a really cool
way to promote your brand you know you
when you saw it on desktop you saw it on
mobile if people are crossed clicking
between your apps it's a good way that
you can show the different featured app
or some of the other apps that you have
but yeah I'm sure at some point that you
know what will release some information
on that okay so I'm guessing for a
single app if the developer has just
want to happen baby it's not as
available but I can clearly see if you
have multiples that's a way to promote I
mean even if you only have one app there
you can still pin it to the top and have
that as sort of your mini featured app
so I think it can still be a strong way
to promote your brand also the cost is
actually very low right like it's a it's
something that takes you a minute and at
the same time like there is no cost
associated with itself so it's bright
it's pretty straightforward and pretty
easy to set up great talk thank you for
sharing yeah I have a question related
to staged rollout can you elaborate a
little bit more about selection of
you and upgrade accusers about upgrading
for the same percentage of users so when
once you have pushed for example we
released it like for ten percent and we
found some critical issues in it and we
roll out a new apk for the same
percentage yep what will happen yeah so
it gets a little trickier so you know we
can we can sink real quick afterwards
and I can show you there's a nice
support page actually in the in the
develop of it that says yeah so you roll
out its point ten percent or something
if you find an issue and you want to
update it you know how do you get that
that update to go to the ten percent if
you want to keep iterating or something
so let's let me come over there
afterwards and I'll show you the page I
believe so because again we don't you
know we don't want to push 10 and you've
issues with it then you're gonna push it
to another ten percent or something so
yeah that's the point of sort of this
staged rollout concept but again i'll
show you guys the actual page where
outlines very very specifically how you
can do that actually we're quite
familiar with this place yeah exactly
was mentioned we'll just the same ten
percent of users receive the update I
believe so yes but if it doesn't say so
specifically on there that one staged
rollout bit then i'm not sure up top my
head but let's follow up i want to get
you the answer and another part what is
the percentage between you and upgrading
theaters when we allowed it to the same
ten percent will it be like five percent
of new users and five percent of
upgrading upgrading to you the floor
something different in terms of who gets
pushed that yes i don't think there's
any specifics i think it's pretty pretty
arbitrary intentionally that you're just
pushes it to a subset of your user base
out there so there is no guarantee that
will be any new user or any update
Achilles I don't believe so but again we
can follow up on that sorry this kind of
specific questions about it but yeah
let's make sure thang
I think so I have a few questions I'll
just do them all at the same time so you
can response in whatever order you see
fit one is a do you have any recommended
strategies for dealing with a sort of
irrelevant user reviews so for example I
work on an app that you know basically
you can buy digital content on and
people are sometimes disappointed to
realize that they actually have to pay
for some for the content and they leave
negative reviews because of that
disappointment they give one star
reviews and it doesn't really you know
it's not a fair review of our app
because you know we don't advertise that
we like we know we're giving away
anything for free so that's one issue so
i can take that real quick so one of the
cool things within the developer console
is you can actually respond to user
reviews so that's something that we
definitely would recommend that
developers do so if you get a one-star
review particularly if it's something
where you know the user should have
known they had to pay for something or
there's an issue like that you can
respond to that user review and it's
going to show up right below that right
i mean we're definitely aware of that
and we've we've tried that with a very
very limited request i mean you know
just you know most users at that point
don't care enough to update the review
or no they're still not happy with like
you know what it still doesn't meet
their expectations so that's one thing
that you know I don't really have a
suggestion for like how to improve but
some sort of know right
having some sort of criteria I like
that's so for example that the helpful
reviews section sort of sorting
theoretically could help but in like
we've noticed on our app that it doesn't
like some of those new reviews are
actually ranked up a pie on the helpful
when it sort of bite helpfulness so
that's one thing if like the helpfulness
could be improved that could actually
help a lesion on maybe what the average
score but with the with the order of the
reason so one of the things that some
developers do if when you're responding
to review that's particularly negative
say hey good and contact us at support
at brians app com or something and then
you have a sort of different form that
you can try to resolve the issue and
then maybe that could incentivize them
to go back later and actually you know
actually update the review update the
star that they put their you can also
you can also really try and test various
different descriptions around it to be
very explicit about like what your app
is all about so that users before the
downloaded really get a good
understanding about like what the app is
all about and you can test various
different descriptions as well so that
lecture to my next question is there any
way it would be I there may be away I'm
not aware of it mr. it would be cool if
you could see the stats for how many
times and if users actually expand the
description because the description as
you see it normally is just like two
lines and then
you know you can't really fit much in
there so it'd be interesting to see a
look how many of those users are
actually reading the description because
I would suspect that you know most don't
I mean I I typically never do myself so
that's that's one thing the show more or
whatever with a tad there yeah so we
don't have any stats around it but it's
definitely something anything that you
think is really really important to
communicate the users make sure to have
it above the fold so that most of the
users actually see it or all of the
users seed there's definitely a break
off as soon as you actually have to
expel okay and and with beta testing
again I have very limited experience but
I was as far as i understand through
well basically I I sort of felt like it
would be nice if there were more avenues
to get input from the beta testers for
example you know if I'm like you know if
I don't have access to a lot of devices
and i'm using my beta testers of sight
okay like you like okay like you have a
samsung device you have a LG device and
you know one of these devices like has a
problem an easier way for that user to
be able to submit either screenshots or
like scream screen recording or
something like that to me so I can you
know see what the issue is it like it
might not be a crash just like it might
be a layout issue or something like that
so that would be really helpful so more
avenues of sort of communication and
data collection of course what the users
are approval in each individual case for
beta testers so there is one way that
you can do that so for beta testing you
can actually now not only use the group
but you can also actually create a link
and that link can be distributed through
whatever channel you want to and so if
you start a campaign and I could be for
example an AdWords campaign where you
can target a specific device then you
can push out your betta BK to a couple
of users there are all on that specific
device which allows you to learn much
more about users for the specific device
that's one way to do it and you can
choose whichever channel use to push it
out but one way that I'm familiar with
is actually if you use that
words and you just target specifically
users that have the specific device and
you'll get feedback from them right
right I'm talking about the next step
where is like if one of those advice has
a specific issue for example a layout
issue you know it'd be nice if I could
that the user could submit you know a
screenshot or a screen recording of that
issue of more easily like right now I
would have to communicate what I use or
ask them hey like here are the steps do
this like your record your screen if you
like please and then you know if they're
nice enough they might do if they're
nice enough and like savvy enough to do
it they might but a more streamlined
experience for the beta testers
themselves what would really be I mean
you can always have feedback mechanism
built within your app right so a lot of
google apps shake to get feedback or
click a click on menu options and
feedback something like that if you're
doing closed beta right you have access
to that Google Group so you can always
work out some type of communication
methods around there but yeah definitely
your feedback though and is there any
mechanism to provide on rewards for beta
testers like if you know if someone
would it was beta tester and they
submitted an issue like you want to like
you know give them a paid version game
of hide or something oh my god visitor
mechanism for that right now I don't
think built in within the developer
console with alpha and beta channels
there is but yeah okay thank you
I what is your appreciation for
prompting in the app feedbacks like
prompting and have the user to give us
some feedback in the prey store is that
work is it recommended is it from upon
what are your thoughts but what do you
mean that the in-app a lot of apps pop
up a dialog asking you if you want to
rate them now mmhmm yeah I'm not sure
off the top my head if I of there we go
screensaver five any particular best
patches or anything around that I can
say if it works at all if it works
you're annoying or something I mean I
certainly find it annoying at some spots
me personally I'm not sure if we have
any best practices around when you
should ask for a rating or when you
extractor feedback but you know I would
say just you know figure out which you
when a user is going to be most likely
to click on that call to action and not
find it annoying so you know probably
someone who's already engaged with your
app probably someone who you know has
spent a certain amount of time there and
maybe giving you a rating or maybe
giving you a reading in a previous
version or something I think there's
definitely some different signals that
you could use to figure out who you
should prompt with that rather than just
sort of spam everybody with it hey guys
have you had any experience with people
having negative feedback from a
developer standpoint alpha beta and
wanting to roll back to a production and
not being able to do so like say for
instance adding a certain feature in a
manifest or raising target SDK and
having that be bumped and then not being
able to take a step backwards that's
tough again I'm I'd say let's let's meet
afterwards and we can look at again the
specifics of when you roll a future out
when you roll it back when you're
pushing a certain percentage pushing
back because I want to give any
misinformation but you know the whole
point though is right you're gonna be
able to push it out to certain set of
users you're gonna be able to iterate
and launch and I suppose you could
always just if you have a previous
version you want to roll back to right
maybe push that one out instead but
again let's let's think afterwards
instead of me trying to tell you off the
top of my head
have you guys seen any successful
strategies for managing it operates and
apps and are you guys working on
anything to make that easier for
developers what's the question if we
have seen any successful premium apps no
good strategies for handling up rates or
paid upgrades or updates sorry yeah you
do a 2 point 0 would be able to charge
for it have you seen any 16 had have any
patterns that are successful for that
and are you guys thinking about it or
have any ideas towards that yeah
definitely there are a couple of
examples out there I really just look at
like apps or games that are there are
doing this successfully I don't want to
actually point one or the other that is
actually of the partners that we work
with point out here but we can sync
definitely later on it's also good
practice to kind of like if you have the
same app right leg over think about is
it hard to get your uses from a paid app
be in many cases it's probably better to
actually keep the users in there and
offer additional content and potentially
upsell your content in there there can
be a break up if you actually want to
push your users to another app but we
can talk about this in detail later on
at the office or if you want to
hey guys really love the new you know
user acquisition capability within the
developer console but I feel there's a
bit of a feature cap right now where you
can't really see a lot of visibility
into what's happening organically within
the store itself so you can certainly
track things that happened outside the
store like a nag campaign but you don't
understand what the organic traffic is
comprised of so what keywords are people
searching for which promotional
positions are driving traffic and so on
and so forth so that'd be a great
feature request yeah totally so at this
point you can see your keyword searches
you can see you TM attack traffic so
that allows you to get an understanding
of your third party traffic but you
cannot dig into all of the details and
so I definitely take that feedback and
that's something that we are actively
working on thank you
hi um I know that you guys have a lot of
statistics on like crashes and that sort
of thing and particularly looking at the
user reviews in the developer console
but as far as I noticed there's no way
to like export them to like a CSV or
something like that is that something
that's coming is that there and I just
been blind and there's there's nothing
that I can share specifically about an
export functionality but definitely read
the reporting that you can see for
reviews you see actually quite a lot of
iterations there and actually updates so
stay tuned honest thanks a quick
question you talked about optimizing
prices for different local markets do
you have any guidance on specifics for
doing that you know if I've got a 99
cent app here in the States what do I do
with that in a hundred other countries
yeah I mean some devs you know with the
new sub dollar pricing options are
testing out a lot of different you know
a lot of different pricing options you
have the option I believe within the
developer console to use the currency
converter right so you can click real
quick and then depending on whatever the
days exchange rates are it's going to
try to figure out the pricing for the
different markets yeah it's still kind
of early days with some of this so you
know I think there are couple sort of
high-level tips and strategies and again
not to plug office hours but I think we
have about two seconds left so yeah if
you want to swing by you know lots of
good stuff also in the app success book
that we can give you that covers some of
the international markets different
monetization strategies and some of the
stuff you can do with the sub dollar
pricing I believe they start at 115
today the location that's a good
question though I think not here you
never any in here I'll be wearing the
same shirt I promise hours or out
Grand Hall okay there we go cool I think
other people are coming in here kicking
us out so thank you
alone